can we do this since we're here in
Columbus let's do it alright come on we
have to we have for the pot alright
ready ready right 100
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bear that she'll be fine
without it
[Music]
hey y'all some exciting news before we
dive into this episode the minimalists
are going to host a private podcast and
live stream exclusively for our patreon
supporters we're calling this ask the
minimalists anything the first session
will take place next month that's August
2017 anyone who contributes two dollars
or more over at our patreon page can
attend this special live stream and if
you can't make the livestream itself the
live session the live podcast don't
worry you'll still have access to the
private video and the private audio
podcast efforts recorded we hope to do
this at least once a quarter maybe more
frequently for our patreon supporters
and please note that none of the money
from our patreon campaign goes to our
personal bank accounts rather what we're
going to do is use these funds to build
our own new podcast studio and a film
studio which is going to allow us to do
a bunch of really cool things like take
live colors on the air improve overall
audio quality and bring guests on the
show we're also going to hire a
full-time filmmaker to create a video
version of this podcast and we also want
to produce a bunch of other meaningful
video creations like webseries TV shows
interviews documentaries video essays
and more and because we refuse to
clutter our podcasts with advertisements
patreon really is the best way for us to
fund these creative endeavors together
so let me ask you this are you willing
to help if so please become a patron
today head on over to patreon comm slash
the minimalists or you can go to our
website it's just the minimalists comm
and click on the donate button at the
top we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well and please know that your
support is greatly appreciated together
we will create something meaningful
well hello everybody my name is Joshua
fields Milburn and I am Ryan Nicodemus
and we are the minimalist live in
Columbus
all right so we have a microphone set up
right back there I believe we looked at
spotlight just turned on and so
eliminating this gentleman beautiful
haircut yes that is a great well sorry
and so usually what happens is it takes
a few moments for someone to break the
ice and then line cascades down to the
microphone afterward Ryan and I we stick
around take photos fish out hugs we
can't answer 500 questions tonight in
line it's a now is the time to ask your
questions but first Ryan as people are
lining up do you know who used to work
in this building this is a State
Building do you know who used to work in
this building Abraham Lincoln wrong
failure Oh in an alternate universe
President John Kasich worked in this
building didn't you live in like West
Chester Ohio or something nice he's here
he's a Governor of Ohio I know that
anyway that's awesome
all right so no I don't see anyone when
I know like they're always we do have a
good person seated there he was
meditating although people are thinking
like usually people are thinking like if
I get in line and no one follows me I'm
gonna be so embarrassed but don't worry
about it by the way I was I was just
joking about all the Ohio stuff I said
during during my talk I absolutely loved
it loved Ohio I don't know why us rips
on Ohio away I grew up in Dayton Ohio
it's been a lot of times in Cincinnati I
spent a lot of time in Columbus as well
I'd come here once or twice a month to
go see concerts usually at the Newport
or at the basement I don't know yeah so
I love the city and I'm grateful you
decided to be here with us tonight
what's your name brother in which were
you from what's your question my name is
Thomas Fletcher and I am from Columbus
Ohio
nice to meet you Thomas thanks for
coming out man thank you
um I have been thinking a lot about
things that I am passionate about and it
really comes down to one word and this
and in its environments I'm passionate
about the kind of environments that
people are working in I passionate about
the environment as a
all and I'm really passionate about also
just a food the food industry and making
sure that things are produced ethically
but about the environments that people
work it has to do with the textile
industry and the clothing industry and
we know that there are a lot of problems
with it and the six words I hate to hear
are that's just the way it is under
something we can do
so how would you to respond to someone
who just says well that's just the way
it is I would say you mean that's the
way that it was and because eventually
all things change and so people don't
necessarily hate change it feels like
that when that that is the objection
they put up because they're they're
trying to maintain the status quo to
some extent right that's just the way it
is means I am comfortable enough to
accept the way this is it doesn't mean
I'm satisfied with it necessarily
because if they were satisfied whether
they give you the actual reasons that it
is what it is here here is why it is and
here here the here's the rationale
behind it or even the emotions behind
why it is what it is but when someone is
clinging to the way something was part
of that sometimes has to do with
nostalgia and by the way I think
nostalgia is kind of dangerous because
it's imagining a past that didn't exist
or it's imagining a past that existed
without the flaws that were actually
there and so when we see things about
constantly glancing in the rearview
wishing you know we could return to this
nostalgic past what that really means is
my vision is blurry and so when someone
says this is the way that it is I would
I would convince them why you need more
leverage basically why something needs
to change
and so you need a more compelling future
than what is comfortable in the present
quite often we don't change because well
it's not that we hate change
we
being changed we hate people trying to
change us but we love positive change we
love feeling compelled to change and so
what I would say to someone who is
telling you that's just how it is you
need to find the leverage to show them
to enlighten the path to what it is
going to be because it can be changed if
you're able to to paint that picture and
in the best possible way
if someone says well that's just the way
it is I would say well yeah with that
attitude I guess it is you know it's
funny this whole minimalism thing for me
it started with reclaiming my time I
mean those like 70 80 hour work sweet
work week's word I used to wear it as a
badge of honor like yeah I'm working
80-hour workweeks
and then it just got to a point where
I'm like what the hell am i doing it was
just it was it was insane but what I'll
say is going down this path has led to a
lot of Awesome side-effects like I can
you know clean my my place faster like
way faster I can move now like so we
live in Missoula Mariah and I we just
moved recently and we hired movers that
was telling someone that and they were
like dude you spent a thousand bucks on
movers and I'm like no I spent like two
hundred fifty bucks on movers like they
can they can move me in two and a half
hours like it's hardly any time because
I don't have a lot of stuff and it's
worth worth it for me to pay 250 bucks
to have someone else put the tax on
their back rather than mine Josh used to
help me but I think I screwed it back up
asked him to help me but but an another
benefit is the environment yeah I
realized like when we you know obviously
when we consume less we produce less
waste and what I'll say is I really love
having just a small part in the
environment that's kind of where my head
is
over the last year or two it really is
on the environment Josh now talk about
it too much because honestly I can't
think of a way to talk about the
environment without being all doom and
gloom and anything that I read it's
there are the only benefit that I can
find to to talk about what the
environment is if you recycle and if you
pay close attention to what you're what
you're throwing away and if you can move
to cleaner energy we won't die or our
kids won't die and that's a great
benefit don't get me wrong I love to
live but you know for all intents and
purposes all the facts that are out
there it is all like doom and gloom
stuff and I like I said Josh and I we
try to keep it as positive as possible
and I don't want to like guilt people
into doing what's responsible but what I
will say is like my whole part in the
environment right now is talking about
consuming less and like I said I think
it's a I think it's a very small part
and what the environment needs right now
but I guess what I would say is you know
for anyone out there who does care about
the environment like choose your role
and what the environment is it could be
as simple as starting to recycle more
starting to use less packaging I mean I
try to use my water bottle whenever
again it's a small thing but you know at
the end of the day there are tons and
tons of plastic wasted every year put in
landfills just because of plastic water
bottles and you know what I don't
remember it every time and I feel like a
jerk when I'm like okay I got to go get
a water and I'll try to get glass and
there's no glass and I'll get plastic
and then you know it's not perfect with
it but what I'll say is is everyone if
everyone chose their role in the
environment it would be so much better
and that rule could even be we had a we
had a high school kid come to our
Washington DC event on tour last year
with our documentary and he came into
the microphone he's like man I really
love engineering and like I really
of making things and I'm so conflicted
because like I want to be a minimalist
but I also want to make things and I
want to sell it to people like how do i
reconcile that and I'm like dude like
make a make a biodegradable cell phone
like if we could just do something like
that that would that would make a lot of
difference or make a biodegradable
plastic water bottle um I saw this
Kickstarter for an edible water bottle
have you seen this I saw it too but it
seemed it seemed like a parody yes it's
a great idea when I first saw them like
this is Jini so you can be like you can
drink your water and have a snack but
then I thought about going to the gas
station and like picking up a water
bottle off the shelf and place it
touching the Shelf and all the dirtiness
around it
it's not like I'm they gotta be eating
that water but you know what if it was
made of chocolate
they'd have to like put it in wrapping
which would completely which would
defeat the whole purpose okay I think I
think I can edible wrapper with but my
point is is that with that attitude of
that's just the way it is then guess
what that is going to be the way it is
but what I would say is everyone out
there if they could just choose a small
role or major role in the environment we
would we would move so much further
along with this whole whatever you want
to call it climate change thing or not
just that but the space we're running
out of um I will make a quick point
because I just learned this last year
there was a whole article that came out
in like the local paper in Missoula
about recycling and everyone's like
really angry in Missoula because they're
you cannot recycle glass in Missoula it
is impossible like they had a dumpster
like a target where you throw your glass
bottles in and like target would recycle
them but what ended up happening is put
people listening at home Ryan just said
recycle and air quotes
what was happening is that they would
just end up putting everything in that
dumpster in the landfill because well a
there is no smelting plant in Missoula
so it would have to reuse the bottles
there's no one that would take the
bottles the B they can't reuse the
bottles if there's even one broken
bottle and that dumpster and when people
want to go dump their bottles and into
the dumpster like it was his glass
everywhere so long story short what I
learned was this because it used to
really bother me about throwing glass
away and Nick going into the landfill
this whole thing I read glass is
actually the least of our worries glass
will actually decompose relatively well
and at the end of the day like it's not
harming the environment in the ground
but like everything else we put in there
is so I'm just doing a little tidbit out
there because it was a huge eye-opener
for me with glass actually but you guys
probably have a smelting plant around
here somewhere I mean that's pretty big
city but glass might be the least of
your worries but I was bleeding all over
the loves rest stop two weeks ago
that's because josh is a bit clumsy and
slow to react but you know no you still
were definitely bleeding all over the
rest of because I wasn't very slow to
react I ran in there with a trail of
blood behind me damn glass bottle down
no it's a great question and then the
environment like like I said it really
weighs heavy on my mind and I have been
trying for the last you know couple
years to really think about like how can
I talk about the environment without
making people feel guilty for you know
consuming the things that they do if
anyone has any good ideas send me a
tweet or send something to a podcast
Jean or something I would love to hear
it
awesome guys thank you thanks lemon oh
yes hi I'm Jeff from here and I'm a
recovering bibliophile and collection
mature a turd so still recovering so
you're the one who understands that
collecting is well planned hoarding Oh
Irie bag and board all my comics and
alphabetize all my books every year so
uh about January spent about three and a
half weeks with my son in Southeast Asia
and
everyone I meant was minimalist so come
back home and after 36 hours of flights
and flight changes my wife picks us up
the airport says oh good you're back
I have a documentary for you to watch
tonight so uh I did watch it and since
then I've been a binge listener at
double speed so it's nice to hear your
podcasts on at the normal speed and you
guys is normal speed but you know it's
catching up so I've actually listened to
every one of them and a few twice so we
have a certificate for you in the back
we appreciate that I'll just photograph
it
Bravo but something I've noticed in the
mid interesting that I've been really
inspired by is seeing you guys draw
inspiration from such a diversity of
voices because I've noticed that we have
kind of a polarized country right now
and specifically like hearing voices
from like Sam Harris to Rob Bell adding
value to your guys lives so what seems
to be a rare quality is a open-minded
soft hearted people so I was curious
about your journey to open-mindedness
and how you continue to grow and
cultivate open minds and soft hearts
that is a phenomenal question you rarely
hear me hear me say that here's so the
two people you mentioned Rob Bell Sam
Harris in particular are two the people
who have had a lasting change their work
is at a lasting change on my life Sam
Harris's in our documentary Felicity you
don't know him he is a world-renowned
atheist but he also dabbles in what he
calls spirituality I think most people
who are religious wouldn't call it
spirituality but but meditation and he
wrote a book not that long ago called
waking up and it's a guide to
spirituality without religion and I
found that fascinating I find his other
work fascinating particularly his his
podcast which is also of the same name
waking up and then Rob Bell who used to
be a megachurch pastor in the Midwest
and has written 10 or 11 books he was on
our podcast recently our LA event and I
think they have both of those guys have
radically different beliefs but I think
they have the same values and some of
those values have to do with
communication and freedom and free
speech and autonomy and contribution and
community and
and and I think that they just use these
different beliefs to get to that same
value at the end of the day and so I I
have I've experienced a bunch of
different points of view because I'm
willing to listen and that's why we're
on tour right now is so we can show up
and listen to people we're getting new
questions all the time afterward we hang
out and we get hugs from people and
we'll hear different statements like
this just these little snippets from
folks and it resonates with me and and
and I can tell you that the people in
this room they're not all like minded in
fact I try not to seek out only
like-minded people Ryan and I have
different beliefs we voted for two
different people in the last election
there was like one like gasp I heard a
door slam I think but you're right it we
are in this climate where it's like I
can't get along with you if you voted
for X or Y and then that is that's so
upsetting to me because I have good
friends who voted for Hillary who voted
for Trump who voted for John Kasich and
the primaries and I what I can tell you
is no matter where you are on that
spectrum we can find some common ground
and I think it's actually my great hope
one day is to get Sam Harris and Rob
Bell together not not to argue this Rob
said something to me a while ago that
really resonated with me he said I'm not
trying to debate I'm trying to help
people hear the music and that's exactly
what I'm trying to do I don't want to
argue with people for the sake of
arguing I want to share something that
has resonated with me this sort of music
of simplifying my life and I think sam
harris wants to do the same thing and I
learned from folks like that and I try
to keep asking questions and I don't
agree with both of them on everything I
obviously couldn't because they don't
agree with each other but I learn a lot
when I keep listening yeah I just try to
have as many variety of opinions as
possible I mean all this in the Rush
Limbaugh listen to Glenn Beck Oh
I mean whoever especially if I hear
someone and I hear like one thing and
I'm like oh like because we I think
we're all are a little guilty this like
go hear someone's opinion on one thing
and you're like oh I hate that person
because that's I don't agree with it
like as soon as I have that thought I
will go out of my way to like listen a
little bit more to like not you know
just have a preconceived you know notion
um and sometimes that's so so
entertaining too you know with some
listen to them but you know without it
hahaha what else save in is uh I just
wanted a long time ago like picking
teams is really stupid um well first off
I was raised like a Buffalo Bills fan
and when I moved to Cincinnati and I
became a Bengals fan it's like the two
worst teams to be fans of in the NFL but
you know what like when the Bengals in
the bills would play like I used to be
torn and then I just got to a point
where I'm like I just want to see a good
game like III don't I don't necessarily
even like um like you know the like the
Indians and the Cubs like the World
Series you know like I was really
pulling for the Indians like those poor
guys same thing with the Cubs like they
were just as bad but the same thing like
I just I looked at those two teams and
I'm like I just wanna see a good game
and it was it was like it was some
really some really good games um I guess
what I'll say is like it's during this
especially during this election like I
just heard so many people like it's this
us versus them thing you know they did
this and we do that we are all us there
is no us vs. them all right
and you know at the end of the day I
just I try to maintain that attitude and
anytime I start to develop any type of
visceral feeling towards towards you
know one one team or the other I would
really try to go out on my way to
understand that team and that has really
helped me to connect with people um
think still really pissed me off
don't get me wrong but but you know at
the end of the day I think just keeping
that that open mind not even you know
hanging out with like-minded people but
just open-minded people who are willing
to at least have a conversation an adult
conversation and that really I think
keeps me sane and I think it also keeps
me you know keeps me having a soft heart
and trying to see from all different
perspectives alright keep on truckin
thanks man thank you
howdy hi my name is Mark Wilson I'm from
Youngstown originally nice excellent
yeah I had a actually a really nice
conversation with a lovely couple from
Youngstown that I'm sitting next to so
that was really cool but um bringing
people together Millie right it's kind
of a driver city but best Keitha in the
world so um so I'm first off thank you
for sharing your message being here
tonight I might not be the best
spokesperson to mention this since I'm a
brand-new member myself but I wanted to
give a quick shout out to the Columbus
minimalism org meetup group thank you
very much man jinsol Records minimalist
org I all my own minimal or guy that's
okay um I'll just give a quick overview
for folks oh so in 2014 Ryan and I did a
crazy 132 or 119 events we donated a
year of our lives doing these free
events and book stores and cafes and
places and and in a few theaters and
people would show up and they'd say hey
how do I connect with other open-minded
people locally and I say I don't know
and they'd be like well you're here
right now but you're getting ready to
leave I'm like well you better hurry up
and find a few people to talk to my
friend them on Facebook do something and
we were like well what if we just left
behind these free local meetup groups so
Ryan and I don't we don't like it's not
a very hands-on approach we leave it up
to you all and we have as a community
leader in 100 cities and some of the
cities are thriving I mean some of the
cities have over 100 people who meet
some some months and other cities it's
you know a dozen or whatever and it's
just free local meetup groups to connect
with people you can talk about stuff and
minimalism and decluttering or
relationships or finances or
contribution or whatever you want to
talk about it's it's kind of a support
group for people with open minds yes and
I definitely benefit from talking to
people about this stuff and like you say
with open-minded people so even in just
the one meetup and I that I've been able
to make it - since I discovered the
group that's been cool so a nice
resource for anyone who might be
interested I figured I'd mention it also
no thanks for mentioning yeah absolutely
um so my question is about managing your
social life so when I initially started
decluttering my life removing some of
the consumptions it wasn't really adding
anything I was able to create a much
more meaningful social life for myself
which was something that was important
to me my relationships with my friends
and family are something that are
important but that itself can become
something of a problem eventually - you
know in a town like Columbus and I know
cities across the country there are
there are no lack of things to do and
while individually each one can be
really good or fun collectively it can
be exhausting or keep you from doing
other more meaningful deliberate things
so my question is what what advice would
you have for saying no to people that
you like and activities you might enjoy
doing but that are collectively not
balanced and creating a balance there in
dealing with some of the stress from
having to cut some of those ties
thank you yeah so is it interesting
where we are we have access to more
activities than ever right we have more
pacifiers all around us we have more
glowing screens than we've ever had we
have more things to do than we ever have
in human history and we're more bored
than we've ever been
isn't that fascinating where I hear it
all the time and I'm just so bored
and what that tells me isn't that people
were actually bored because there are
limitless choices right now especially
in cities but even outside of cities now
you have the internet there you know
Ryan and I lived in a cabin in the
middle of nowhere for four months like
middle of nowhere Montana we found the
way to get internet there we had to like
negotiate with the phone company to make
it work but it worked out and once you
have that you have access to the world
at your fingertips sort of thing but you
use the word there you said meaning and
and I think what we're lacking right now
is meaningful engagement now what does
that mean I think it's different for
everyone for some some people it's deep
work Cal Newport a friend of ours who's
a computer scientist and author he wrote
a book called deep work he wrote another
one called so good they can't ignore you
and he he talks about sort of the
dangers of some of these distractions in
our lives and while I am I don't take
the same sort of Luddite approach that
he would of you know he's never been on
social media in his life I do have to
find ways to use those things more
deliberately
and also avoid using them when they are
just my go-to you hear this phrase all
the time I'm just going with the flow I
think it's a problem because when we go
with the flow eventually you end up at
the falls and if you get there and you
weren't prepared for the falls you are
in for a world of hurt and so doing
meaningful work B for create creative
work or also having deep meaningful
conversations and relationships with
fewer people that's important and that's
like but that's paddling the other way
that's headed upstream it's more
difficult work but you'll get a lot more
out of
with respect to saying no to those
people I think it takes practice I think
you have to get good at saying no you
won't be good at it at first and I've
even with me I've been testing some
stuff out lately just just to see if I
can expand my sort of palette of of
saying no I've gotten pretty good at
saying though and think instead of I
think instead of saying no just saying
though tell people what you're saying
yes to instead so someone asks you to do
something say you'll say no I can't do
it I'm busy I'm busy means my life is
out of control and I know that anytime I
say I'm busy it means I'm probably
letting other people dictate how it's
been the hours in my day because we all
have the same 24 hours in a day and how
we spend those we get to choose and so
instead of just saying no I can't do
that what I'll say is the reason I'm
saying no to this is so I can say yes to
this I need to have a four year old I
want to spend time with her my partner
Rebecca or you know what I need to go
out on tour so I'm going to say yes to
that right now
in fact I've had I have a list of like
six or seven people or close friends who
I need to call as soon as we're back off
of the road because I know I can't give
them my full attention right now so I
say no to them this week so I can say
yes to them next week and I think if
they get good at that we were at the
rental car place in Indianapolis and
instead of just saying no to the guy
they always ask me do you want this / -
this protection for $26 a day I said yes
I'll take it for $5 a day
I think so I can't do that soon as you
can because I said I'll take it for five
dollars a day I ended up getting it for
seven but still if you practice it's a
new way of saying no because really what
I was saying is no I don't want that but
instead of like you trying to have
something I'm going to disarm you by
saying how can I say yes to this in a
way that is beneficial to both of us
yeah practicing knows definitely it
helps so much man I'll say the other
thing to set boundaries for yourself
like if you are saying yes to going to
concerts or game night or going out to
eat whatever it is it's like what are
you saying no towards and if it's if
it's stressing you out then like if
you're not getting your work done or
your chores done or whatever it may be
like you've got to start setting some
boundaries for yourself I think that's
the thing about this whole this whole
minimalism thing and you don't have to
call it minimalism call it simplicity or
deliberate ISM or whatever you want I
mean for me it helped me set those
boundaries and I'll tell you in Missoula
there are so many cool people in
Missoula and like every time I go to
like like my buddy throws this this
Spring Fling every spring like the first
day of spring and like 150 people show
up and I go I'll try to go you know
every year when he has it and this year
I met so many cool people and they're
like oh man like we should hang out more
I'm like man I would love to I was like
but there's so many cool people in
Missoula it's hard for me to hang out
with everyone now it's funny because I
think about like the friends I have in
Missoula that I will hang out with when
you know when we have free nights like
Mariah and I we actually have like a
group text we'll just like send it out
and then people will start responding
and we'll try to get to get like
everyone gets you know try to get try to
get
everyone together so we're not just like
kind of singling out people but there is
this whole other circle on the outside
that lake as soon as you know couple
people move out or you know drop off or
whatever move out of the city and
somehow like you know we're not hanging
out anymore like there are people like
I'm just ready to pull into like to hang
out with but I have to set that boundary
I don't have that I don't have a number
on you know the people that I hang out
with but what I'll say man is like
anyone in your life who who respects you
like they're gonna understand they say
no and your friends like if you're
telling them yes when you should be
saying no like I think when I do that
like I'm not really being a good friend
because you know if Josh was to tell me
yes when he meant no like josh is an
introvert most of you all know this so
you know before the show if I'm like hey
do you want to go get some dinner like
I'm pretty sure he's gonna say no he'll
say you know say something like I'm
gonna go enjoy a walk okay man whatever
but if he was to tell me yes and then we
went to dinner and then you know we get
back
like I know Josh would not have that
alone time that he needs to to do his
best and I don't want to take that away
from him so again like if Josh was to
tell me yes when he should be saying no
to give himself what he needs I would
feel like a bad friend personally so
like don't be scared to say no set some
boundaries and I hate to say it man but
you're going to miss out on a lot of
stuff in fact right now you're missing
out on 99.999% of everything else is
going on in the world like you have
decided to be here with us tonight which
is all semantics are coming out but but
don't be scared of what you're missing
out on because you will always miss out
on something it's more important on it's
more important to focus on what your
priorities are and stick to those and
your friends will totally understand
yeah thanks guys appreciate you
they're real quick before we move on to
the next question
but the people were listen to this at
home if you have a comment or tip for
anyone who has asked us a question today
or anyone who's going to ask us a
question then leave us a voicemail at
four zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine or you can actually send a
voice memo right from your phone now -
you can email it over to podcast at the
minimalists comm we will air our
favorite comments and tips at the end of
this episode and also at the end of
future episodes as well hey Ryan what
time is a it is time for our hashtag ask
the minimalists lightning around where
usually we answer questions from social
media you know we're on the Twitter's
and Facebook and Instagram and what else
Yik yak I don't think we found out for
you yeah yes yes but yeah usually we'll
take questions to social media but you
know since you're here would be weird if
like Josh and I were on our phones
answering questions so basically with
Josh and I are going to try and do is
you ask a question we're going to try
and give you like a pithy 140 character
answer now usually we have about a week
to prepare for this and now we've got
like you know maybe five seconds so we
might ramble a little bit but I promise
you eventually we'll get to a pithy
answer we call the minimal Maxim's we
also put them in the show notes as well
so you'll get a regular answer but then
we'll tie it up with a bow at the end
with one of those minimal Maxim's that
any of you can can tweet which by the
way Jessica Williams who runs all of our
social media she's usually live tweets
these things and so if you want to
search that you can just use the hashtag
for our tour it's alessa's now tor so
the hashtag is just less is now you'd
find that on we're at the minimalists on
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram
howdy what's your question yeah that's
actually a nice segue because you are as
literally the minimalist across the
board on Twitter Twitter Facebook you
are a brand and so my question is what
struggles or expectations have come with
that and even just hearing the last
question what things have you had to say
no to as you've grown because you're I
mean now your public figures
and you know what comes with that yeah
it it whenever you call yourself the
minimalists everything you do is
instantly blanketed with like this layer
of irony and so if I don't have a
minimal number of social media followers
or whatever it buddy very minimal hair
you have over there Josh I thank you but
no you're right there is some inherent
complexity that becomes layered in when
you open yourself up to sort of the the
public life in a way so I'll answer a
slightly different question and
hopefully it'll it'll get to where we're
going here but I strive for congruence
in my life and what I mean by that is
there is not a personal and a public jsm
and that's important to me I had a
friend who was going to applying to med
school a few years ago and she she was
like I don't I'm really worried about
you know the stuff that's on my facebook
account and like other people being able
to see that and and what that told me is
that she was being one person here and
one person over here and I I strive to
be the same whether I'm in front of a
group of people or I'm by myself and so
being in the public eye in one way it
actually helps me put my best foot
forward
now that doesn't mean I don't have a
private life I do you know I'm not going
to if it doesn't make sense if it
doesn't sort of the greater good you're
not you're never going to see the
minimalist sex tape there was one person
clapping
[Laughter]
yeah but you're also not going to see me
like take a picture of here's the the
bacon and eggs I'm meeting this morning
for breakfast and putting it up there
because for me that doesn't serve the
greater good it's part of my private
life in a way and and so um oh here we
go a congruent life is a well lived life
that's what put the answer for you
man um I uh I say no to a lot um
hey Josh how do you know when someone
quit Facebook don't worry they'll tell
you so I quit Facebook recently I mean
we solved the minimalists obviously
which by the way we are the minimalists
because the domain was available for
like eight bucks we started this whole
thing um but yeah I I was helping out
with minimalist org and like when people
send me from requests like I hated to
say no and then people tagged me and
stuff I just I hate ignoring the the
tags and oh my god the message requests
my goodness like ignoring those is like
the hardest thing I have to do or that I
had to do um but I got to a point where
Josh and I we as an experiment deleted
all the social media apps off of our
phone which made me intentionally have
to go to Facebook on my computer and we
did this at the beginning of this tour
it was stressing me out every day like
every single day I was like oh my god I
got 200 notifications I have to find
Wi-Fi I have to make sure it's secure I
have to go through check 200 messages
oh my only have a half hour you know
between flights right now or but at this
rest stop or whatever it is and I'll
check 100 now let's check I mean it was
just driving me insane so it got to the
point where I'd to say no I'm like you
know what this is silly like I am NOT
going to stress over this anymore in at
the end of the day like the only reason
I was on Facebook was to to encourage
other people but it was to answer those
notifications and if I would just simply
ignore those notifications well then I
would never get on Facebook so it made
no sense for me to like say on there so
I yeah I got rid of it and I'm still
alive ladies and gentlemen um yeah and I
guess I don't miss adjust I just prefer
talking to my friends face-to-face so
break in mid-sentence we won't even be
talking about social media at all and
like I'll be talking about something I
think is profound there's some metaphor
that's esoteric and and always had to
look in the others ago yeah I guess I
don't miss it um yeah did you ever pithy
answer oh um I ever supposed come up
with the answer for yep no I I think I
would say don't just say no for the sake
of saying no be clear on what you're
saying yes to looks good thank you thank
you
howdy what's your name hi I'm Bailey
hello Haley hello we from right here in
Columbus okay not right here like the
Joey
Davison theatre no not right like where
I'm standing currently but like 15
minutes down the road ish okay yeah okay
so much your essence it I'm just kidding
ah
first of all how are you how is Columbus
treating you goddamnit good I'm so glad
that just makes me happy okay so my
question for you is I am a 20 year old
girl who moved back in with her parents
whilst studying at Ohio State in order
to save on the cash money okay yes so I
am a Buckeye and my older sister and I
who is a year older and also with me
here tonight are oh there she is
are slowly but surely trying to
transform ourselves into minimus and
living the minimalism lifestyle which is
difficult when we are living with a mom
dad sister and two brothers who want
nothing to do with we have introduced
the idea they've seen us get rid of like
all of our stuff we've minimized our
wardrobe our our bedroom has like just a
couple few things that mean a lot to us
we've gotten rid of half of the
furniture in there but the rest of our
house is ridiculously packed with
clutter like kid you not we have the
secret storage unit in our basement that
has like [ __ ] ton of stuff in it like
books
my mom has different sets of dishes for
every holiday dude like Christmas
Valentine's Day and they come out for
that holiday and then they get put away
like we have so much stuff and it drives
me of the wall but I got to live with
them right now so what do you recommend
for
moenay's trying to live that lifestyle
with surrounded by like five other
people who don't want to do it
I would not recommend moving back in
with your parents and then telling them
to get rid of all her [ __ ] that's my
pithy answer good you know III think
that what do you have a plan on how long
you're going to live there is it several
years um I know do you know at this
point what the timeline looks like at
the timeline honestly right now probably
till I'm done with school which is like
two to three years so quite some time
but in fact like maybe it's not a ton of
time but it seems like a lot right now
sure sure but if you pan out the I guess
my my Pippy answer for you and I'll try
to unpack this a little bit yeah my pity
answer for you is my minimal maximum is
on a long enough timeline everything is
ephemeral and and so two-three years
from now you'll look back at it and say
I learned a lot from this experience and
here's what I want you to learn from
this experience because I agree with
Ryan yeah the worst actually I think
that's the second worst thing to do is
move in tell them together so the worst
thing for you to do would be good to go
there and start getting rid of their
stuff by the way you all know it's way
easy to get rid of other people's stuff
than it is to get rid of your own stuff
I Ryan was doing the packing party and I
found 40 coffee mugs and I had this
trash bag I was just sweeping hahahahaha
he's like way what are you doing I need
that just a case I put out one and said
world's number one grandpa on it and it
was a mug he had never used anyway
anyway I think that it's it's important
for you to learn some lessons during
this time so right now control what you
have control over altima controls an
illusion anyway but you do have some
control over over your space and your
you and your sister in the same room
yeah that like you're mostly on the same
page or at least reading from the same
book
and the thing I'll tell you though is
here's another pit the answer for you
beware of drowning people they will also
drown you and quite often we we try to
think we're doing something helpful
because someone else is drowning and
stuff and and I think metaphorically
quite often we get we get taken down
with it and so I want you to go through
a bit of this is going to be the perfect
time for you to learn this there's an
acronym that the Ryan and I like to
think about when we think about
understanding other people because
they're not the same place that you are
mentally physically emotionally in their
life whatever and it may just take a
while for them to get to that place so
you guys keep showing them the benefits
but the acronym that in the meantime
that you're going to have to deploy your
own life it's Tara t-ara you want to
tolerate the person that's the first
thing you got to look at the stuff and
say you have your Valentine's Day fine
china or whatever it is and okay if you
use it so be it if you don't use it I
have to tolerate that it's your house
this is your place and and this is going
to be an experiment in my own tolerance
but I'll tell you this tolerance is a
good first step but it is a weak virtue
if you just tolerate someone for long
enough you will feel resentment over
time for that person and so we have to
go beyond tolerance the next a the TA
the a is acceptance we have to accept
the things for how they are we have to
break up with the idea of how you want
things to be you want to live in a
pristine container home with clean lines
and white walls and you know whatever I
mean and I understand that and you will
get there but in the meantime let's
accept things for how they are and also
that acceptance lets you realize that
maybe it's not as bad as you think it is
and then beyond that is the are the big
leap to this are if the respect them a
because it's their house but be because
you love them and they might have
different beliefs from you and that's
okay Ryan and I aren't here trying to
convert anyone to minimalism
want to share a recipe if you see some
of the benefits that we've experienced
and you want to tweeze out a few of the
ingredients from our recipe apply it to
your own life grade if not that's
totally okay to no judgment for me no
judgment from Ryan I still respect you
as a person and the last leap and I say
leave because it is like self
actualization leap you can get to that a
the final a and t-ara it's appreciation
you want to be able to appreciate them
warts and all and say I know what you
know I think you get value from that and
you're demonstrating that that Christmas
decoration or whatever you love it
you're you're getting joy from it it
serves a purpose in your life and while
it's not something that I would choose I
appreciate that because I appreciate you
and if you can get there over the next
two years you're going to learn a lot
about them but you're going to learn a
whole lot more about yourself
that really was my pity answer but I do
want to expound a little bit going
through that process that's really the
only way you're going to help him move
forward because think about oh I think
about when I was like a really really
like hardcore Jehovah's Witness and like
my beliefs were so strong ik no I mean
no one could move those beliefs and when
people would argue with me other
Christians like would argue with me
about beliefs of dribs witnesses the
more they would throw you know doctrine
or scriptures or you know just
especially like you know really angry
egregious words at me all that would do
is like solidify my believe it would
just make me hold my ground stronger and
it's the same exact thing with your
parents supporting them accepting them
that is the only way you're going to
help them them move forward I am NOT
like a practicing Jehovah's Witness
anymore I don't have anything against
that I just I've been able to move on
and it's not because I was bashed into
not believing it it was because I had
you know I have good people around me
who support me and eventually I kind of
you know got there on my own I can
probably talk for an hour on that but I
won't but anyway yeah that's that's that
I just wanted to expand my Josh's point
a little bit is that is the only way
you're going to get them to move forward
beautiful thank you thank you
all right so I'll apologize to anyone
else but this will be our last question
here because we'll have to move on
before the theater kicks us out we got
some other stuff to cover tonight as
well howdy what's your name
my name is kit yeah good and I grew up
in Thailand time while you guys are on a
Thai restaurant tours we are did you all
know the best Thai restaurant in the
United States that I've discovered so
far is in Dayton Ohio really ty nine
check it out it's right down the street
it's worth the our drive down there it's
awesome well I also go to a place called
my house so oh nice we're able to Alan
we've found this you want to check out
the menu do you make a good massaman
curry um
I don't eat curry that much okay so I
think it's amazing because I was like
closing my eyes sometimes listening and
when I open them you're right here and
you're not coming out of my phone so
we're the voice in your head sometimes
all the time you make my folding laundry
cooking walking the dog flying on the
plane all those things so much more
exciting so thank you thank you thank
you and I have a really short question
and that is what you guys really excited
about right now just first thing that
comes to mind one each that's all put
the answer I got a one-word answer for
you Rebecca
not going to expand on that at all are
you getting married you got a ring on
your ring finger over there that's a
sleep tracker Oh I've been married once
and that was enough but to me like a
contract or a ring or whatever doesn't
does an equal commitment showing up
every day and being willing to show
people that that person that you care
and you're willing to go out of your way
to say you appreciate them but not not
just say it demonstrate that
appreciation for the other person so
we've been on tour for a little bit and
we get to see each other sporadically
you know find a second word I'd say Ella
it's our our 4 year old but yeah
Rebecca's love of my life and I'm
grateful I get to go see here in two
days yeah mm nothing I say will compare
to that I mean I can't just sit and say
Mariah now no I can maybe I should oh
I'll say something different but what I
will say is that having having an
amazing partner in your life not not
just an amazing partner but a supportive
partner it is it's priceless like mariah
is the first relationship I've had where
I truly feel supported and like the
sacrifices she makes so I can go out and
do this she's actually here I think
she's like heard this talk a million
times so I think she's back coding right
now but she's going to a coding school
she has to do this like six or eight
hours a day like sometimes I look at her
screen and I'm like are you hacking into
the matrix like what is going on in um
but my point is is like she has to come
on like if she chooses to come on the
road she she really has to get in six to
eight hours of school every day so she
just sacrificed a lot my point is is
that if you are someone out there who
has an amazing partner in your life like
you've got to get up every day and say
thank you to each other you've got to go
out of your way every day to show each
other that you appreciate it
and if you don't do that right now
that's okay you can start right now but
I'm telling you like having a supportive
partner that is it's the most it's just
it's just priceless it's it's I've never
been happy and Mariah has a lot to do
with that for sure
so and I know Josh has never been
happier and Beck and Becks has a lot to
do with that um what I what I'm excited
about right now oh man that wasn't it no
that is it I just didn't want to like
steal Josh's answer I feel really I feel
like I'm cheating doing that um I think
right now I am I'm just I'm excited
about my 40 year old self like I'll be
36 this year and uh why did you give me
that look because I thought you were 40
oh yeah because I'm still no no no cuz
I'm 41 so oh okay okay I thought you
were 35 thank you I lied no it's not but
anyways um no I really am excited for
the next five years like I don't know
what the next five years are going to
hold for us but we've got some really
exciting stuff that that we are working
on right now we just had a meeting with
Netflix I think it was last week
maybe week before that whenever was a
week or two ago and it's not like there
was any groundbreaking you know series
or special that that was pitched or
anything but I'm really excited about
getting this story and getting this
message out to more people but not only
that but like just digging deeper with
minimalism like I felt like we did that
with a documentary we did I feel like we
did a really good job of showing some
different perspectives covering some
different topics for the longest time it
was like it's just it was just the Josh
and Ryan show don't get me wrong I think
we're awesome
but like two thirty year old white dudes
resonates with only so many people so
being able to dig into things like the
environment the hidden costs of
consumption finances privilege things
like that like I'm really excited about
kind of tackling some some of those
topics and that's my pity answer thank
you thank you all right let's move on
real quick to our added value segment of
the show this is where Ryan and I talk
about something that's added value to
our lives recently and since we're in
Columbus Ohio let's let's have a little
bit of a a local flare to that Ryan
what's adding value to your life in
Columbus Ohio
man I just ate I just hated this
restaurant called Tiger and Lilly anyway
thought of the street yeah it's it's
just like a few blocks away
it was pretty phenomenal like you just
go there and like they have rice bowls
and salad bowls and if you haven't been
there like it's pretty affordable and
it's delicious awesome yeah there there
are two things that I want to mention
one I haven't been there this trip and I
didn't really get to appreciate it the
way I think I would appreciate it now
that I have a four year old co-sign like
seven years ago I went there on a date
and it was like a terrible day
but if I could bring Ella there now I
think I'd have and I know she would have
a pretty awesome time so if you have
kids and the reason I bring that up even
is I grew up in Dayton and there's the
Air Force Museum there I took moving
away to actually go there like I didn't
go to there for Steven so I came back to
Dayton at a time I had been there before
that I was like three maybe and so we
often don't appreciate the things that
we have going on locally so I would
encourage you to check that out also
there's a really interesting coffee
house not too far from here and the
coffee was quite good it's called the
Roosevelt yeah and and they said like
Stumptown coffee and they did a really
good job and the baristas were friendly
but I love what they did they're
nonprofit and all of their profits go to
help out with human trafficking and to
develop clean water and also I'm missing
one other thing but it's see this both
locally and worldwide so and they have
like on their tables they have these
like annual report to show you exactly
where all the profits from from that
business that nonprofit business went
for 2016 and I'm grateful for places
like that because they can do something
cool locally and then do something cool
with that money locally and also do
something cool worldwide as well to help
other people and I really do believe
that giving is living so being a support
businesses that support other people I
mean it's really a win-win so it give
them a shot if you if you get the chance
oh and one other thing for added value I
wanted to bring Jess out here she said
we should so Jessica Williams are you
around here somewhere come on over
speaking of adding value someone who
adds a mint value to our lives she
didn't I was going to say that she just
thought she was going to come out here
and do a selfie with us but or for us
rather she runs all of our social media
and let's give her a round of applause
yeah
so here's the thing about social media
we actually met Jess on Twitter and and
and you know we've we've worked together
for a while now she handles a social
media she comes out on tour with us and
it makes everything so much more
seamless she also does the merch booth
afterward as well she helps take photos
she straightens Ryan's hair occasionally
and she's an all-around outstanding
person and just really grateful you're
here thank you so much for being here
let's do a photo together y'all all
right my hair is awful what's going on
with my hair right now no one warned me
which we do time lapse what is this
every is a cell phone before they weigh
just me you're on the wrong side here we
go here we go
all right yeah that was the first time
we tried that before like horrible yeah
well I didn't have the phone to me you
know I'm in company get the longer arms
that's true I do monkey arms all right
let's move on right here right now is
where we talk about what's going on in
the lives of the minimalist this is
usual where we talk about all of our ads
and sponsors right
what mattresses are we promoting tonight
the mattress yeah or what underwear
company I hear these advertisements and
podcasts all the time for sweat wicking
underwear what about food delivery right
there just reposed to be so many sweaty
asses out there there is such pent-up
demand for the sweat working underwear
no I mean actually I'm not I'm not
judging other people who do ads but
here's the truth
we can have fun joke around about it but
you see about 5,000 advertisements a day
and we don't want to make it 5,000 and
one and we give up a lot of money to be
able to do that and it's not about money
for me and Ryan we're doing just fine
but we want to be able to do some really
cool stuff with our podcasts also with
some new video content we're going to
make some meaningful video film crea
chins so we want to do a bunch of stuff
we're going to create different podcast
podcast interviews shorter episodes
longer episodes more episodes we want to
do a lot of video stuff as well so we're
building a podcasting studio in a film
studio and we could use your help
so if you're willing to help us out we
want to keep this 100 percent
advertisement free because we think
advertisements suck so you can you can
help us out you can head on over to the
minimalists com click on the donate
button we set up something called a
patreon page which we'll find there you
can donate on a per episode basis if you
can afford it and that's going to help
us build this podcasting studio and also
pay our producer podcast Sean a
full-time living wage which or continue
to pay him a full-time living wage which
is three kids certainly appreciate by
the way he's hiding back there he's
always in the shadows ladies and
gentlemen podcast Sean yeah we love you
Sean he does so much for the seat on the
road he is our he's our tour manager
actually I was looking at the there's a
little he's like a little he's a
dressing room I don't know what are you
changing into Sean and on the door says
Sean Harding tour manager and then
underneath it says Jessica Williams
everything else and but really Sean is a
lot of the everything else is Sean he is
our operations guy he is our tour
manager he's our podcast producer and
he's an all-around outstanding human
being and so we're trying to help them
out with that as well so none of the
money that is donated to the podcast
goes to me or Ryan shut the front door I
think I need nicer black t-shirts man so
we were going to get minimalist
Lamborghini I said a Lamborghini okay
all right cool well yeah if you wanna
help us out that's the best way to do it
head on over to our patreon page or our
page and we would certainly appreciate
the support we get 2,000 patrons that'll
give us enough funds to to start
building that studio we get the five
thousand we're also going to hire a
full-time filmmaker we're going to do
many documentaries and web series and a
bunch of other meaningful stuff that
you'll be able to share with folks we
want to put that out in the world and
you can help us create that also we're
in the middle of a tour right now it's
called the
is now tour so folks who are listening
to this at home we're headed to 40
cities Canada east coast down south out
west the mountain states everywhere in
between 40 different cities over at les
is now calm before we head out of here
let's say thanks to the Joe and Davidson
theatres for having us here in Columbus
tonight
we'll be out there afterward if you
decide to pick up a book from us please
minimize it afterward and for some
reason you to bring your wallet or if
you just can't afford a book let us buy
you one we'll be happy to buy a copy for
you afterward so she goes about 20
minutes we will be out in the lobby
dishing out hugs taking photos signing
books all that fun stuff before we leave
here is one last person I want to thank
and that person is you I know it cost
some money to get in here tonight and
we're thankful for that because it
allows us to rent out these beautiful
spaces and have a tour promoter and
patien and just to come out and fly them
out and and put them in hotels and it
also allows snaps and security staff and
all this other stuff we used to just
show up at bookstores but it'd be really
hard to show up at a bookstore with five
or six hundred people now so we're
grateful that you decided to spend that
resource but you spent your two most
precious resources with us tonight and
that's your time and your attention and
you can't get that back and we're
grateful you decided to spend a little
chunk of that time and attention with us
if you leave here tonight with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks y'all
[Applause]
[Music]
hi guys my name is Elizabeth Charlie and
I'm calling from Vancouver British
Columbia Canada
I just finished listening to your
podcast this week with your guest rich
and I really like the podcast I thought
it was good because it focused a little
more on like values and time as opposed
to material goods but one thing I
noticed when I'm listening to your
podcast every week is that when you guys
get to the section about things that
adds value to your life you mostly
mention things that you have purchased
and this week I thought that because it
was less about material goods but not
about shopping and that kind of stuff
that you guys might say Oh something
that's added value to my life is like
your guest rich you mentioned how much
he liked the feeling of having the Sun
hit his shoulder early in the morning
and so he had worked towards making that
more a part of his life as you can
probably hear myself is run gold baby
in the background right now and I'm at
home with him on maternity leave so we
do listen to your podcast every week and
incorporating minimalism has become
really good for us because as a new
mother you're going through this whole
new shaping of a new identity and it's
really forced me to stop thinking about
material things and start thinking about
my mental and emotional health and
well-being and that of my son so without
really realizing it I've been making
changes every week and I just wanted to
share with you what we've been doing the
last couple weeks to add value to our
lives last week we started visiting with
our neighbors next door they're an
elderly retired couple and we found out
that the husband has esophagus cancer
and so he is loving his time with my
little boy Eric and it's really brought
a lot of value to our lives because it
gets Eric out of my arms for a couple
hours and someone brings me some snacks
and lots of water and also they get time
with a little five month-old baby which
is bringing some a lot of joy another
thing I did this week was I just stopped
looking in the mirror my new is Tuesday
hasn't been too far into the week but as
a new mom we're constantly feeling
pressured by society like let's bounce
back and get our mom bots back into
shape and I was like you know what I've
had enough of it is not going to look in
the mirror so much just kind of enjoy
myself
and I feel so much better I feel really
happy and I don't feel a self-conscious
about how I look as a mom and what I do
happen to catch my reflection what I
noticed is that I look happy and that
makes me seem much prettier in my own
eyes and I hope that that will carry
over with my friends and my husband and
other people in my life
hi Joshua and Ryan this is crystal
calling from Seattle Washington and I
wanted to chime in with a comment
regarding grips and following it from
both Claire's question a few podcasts
ago as well it's a follow up from the
gentleman in Scotland and we have in our
household which is her feet we've
adopted what we like to call approaching
a zero-waste lifestyle and we've been
very inspired by the Johnsons of Marin
County California on the zero-waste home
website and a lot of the issues we come
up with are when we do need to shop and
what is it scripts look like when we're
engaging with salespeople and ironically
we just our fourth of July at the mall
my husband needed to pick up a few goods
and we also find some of our low to
non-tactical that we buy a couple times
a year are available there so what it
looks like as far as a script for a lot
of people who partake in a zero-waste
lifestyle is having a discussion upfront
and usually when you meet at go to the
register you'll be offered a bag maybe
some samples maybe a magazine and maybe
some more product that you don't need
and I'm just straightforward with them
up at the desk I approach them I greet
them and firmly with a smile and eye
contact say something along the lines of
you know how are you today once we have
to chitchat out of the way say something
along the line
you know I don't need a bag and if you
can avoid paying a receipt I don't need
that as well I prefer to keep as little
take as little goods as possible that
are just going to wind up in the
landfill or recycling and that usually
elicits a few questions and I'm happy to
share some tips with a person who asks
me at the store and I also shop with my
own good whether it's a dry bag for bulk
food or just my own grocery bags or some
places and let you bring your own leak
for jars in for meat if at the
supermarket so having a script and being
prepared and being kind and firm about
it has been really helpful for the
shopping that we do need to do hi Josh
and Ryan my name is Kim and I'm calling
from Denver Colorado I come from a
family of pack rats and hoarders and
from a culture where people are
constantly comparing each other with the
haves and have-nots growing up I always
thought I if I made a lot of money and
owned a house I'd be happy but like both
of you I made a lot of money and I spent
even more in 2015 my father had a stroke
and I was laid off on my job my parents
lived in another state so it made things
difficult to help out my family while
trying to find a new job but because of
all my parents clutter it made it
difficult to maneuver around their house
and even weeks before his stroke my dad
buddy even told him to start paring down
his clutter because if anything were to
happen to him it would be a real pain in
the you-know-what to get everything
sorted out during the holidays I went
home to help my mom to purge all the
clutter in their house which was an
ongoing battle that I finally just gave
up on and I started listening to your
podcast at the end of 2016 because my
own life was full of cluttered cluttered
with items people obligations emotional
and financial distress and I felt really
lost listening to your podcast actually
gave me some clarity and ideas about
what living a meaningful life meant to
me I began to donate and sell items I no
longer used started to say no to
obligations and was more intent with the
time and attention I gave to others I
then sold my 1,300 square foot townhouse
and moved into
613 square foot rental apartment
actually a couple months ago and this
moved helps me get out of debt which was
a huge weight lifted off my shoulders as
well as bring other meaningful
experiences into my life
now while this journey hasn't been easy
as you guys have said living simple
doesn't mean easy it's actually been one
of the best decisions I've made to
venture into living my minimalist
lifestyle
[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little thing is being that to me
every little singing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it
[Music]
every little singing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for me you got a grand oh I
bet that you'd be fine without so tear
your eyes
[Music]